each small square on the grid has an
area of one square unit so each of these
small squares is one square unit this
square is one square unit and this
square is one square unit and so on and
now we're asked to draw a rectangle with
an area of 10 square units well this
word area here is talking about how much
space our shape covers so our shape in
this case is a rectangle so we're being
asked to draw a rectangle that covers
ten square units and we know that each
of these is one square unit so we want
two rectangle two covers ten of the
square units we could try just drawing a
rectangle right across this top row
until we get ten square units but the
problem there is there's only one two
three four five six seven square units
going across the top so we can't just do
one long row of ten square units we
can't do one long column either because
one two three four five six only six
square units so we can't draw a
rectangle going down like that either
because we need 10 square units so that
means we're going to have to break up
our ten into equal groups since it can't
all fit on one row we're gonna have to
break up the unit squares into groups so
we can break up a ten into two groups of
five or five groups of two either one of
those will work so let's do that let's
draw ourselves a rectangle we'll start
up here here's a rectangle and let's see
that's five and we can space make sure
that covers the whole square unit there
we go
so here's our rectangle and this
rectangle covers one two three four five
there's the first row five and the
second row five has unit squares six
seven eight
9 and 10 so here's one perfect answer a
rectangle that has two rows of five
square units and we could have drawn
this rectangle anywhere on the grid it
doesn't matter we could have drawn it
down here with two rows of five or right
here with two rows of five any rectangle
covering two rows of five has an area of
ten unit squares similarly any rectangle
covering five rows of two let's look and
see if we can try to show that here we
go here's a rectangle and this one will
cover one two so we've rows of two and
there's five rows so one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten so again
this rectangle covers ten square units
so any rectangle that you can draw on
the grid that either covers two rows of
five square units or five rows of two
square units is a rectangle with an area
of 10 square units